After all this time, Spider-Man never met
Hawkeye? Or Loki? What kind of spider is he,
anyway? A recluse? Want more surprising MCU heroes
that never entered Spidey's web? Keep watching.
While it's true that Peter Parker and
Natasha Romanoff fought as allies under
team Tony Stark in "Captain America:
Civil War," the two arachnid-themed
Avengers didn't really get to know
each other at the Airport battle.
As audiences saw in Peter's videos of his
trip to Germany in "Spider-Man: Homecoming,"
the young hero didn't take part in Iron Man's
strategic meetings with his fellow Sokovia Accords
enforcers — and when Spider-Man leapt into battle,
most of his energy and attention went to fighting
the Falcon, the Winter Soldier, Captain America,
and Ant-Man. By the time the skirmish ended,
Natasha had already run away after turning
traitor, while Spider-Man was taken out of
commission due to injuries sustained from the
giant-sized Ant-Man's accidental backhand.
Spider-Man and the Black Widow would later
find themselves fighting against a common enemy
once more, albeit on different battlegrounds,
in "Avengers: Infinity War," but it doesn't seem
like they had a chance to cross paths. Spidey was
taking the fight directly to Thanos on Titan while
Black Widow fought in the Battle of Wakanda
to stop Thanos' forces from taking the last
Infinity Stone. Sadly, Peter was among those who
vanished in the Blip — and while he did manage to
return to the land of the living, Natasha had
to sacrifice her life to make that possible.
Save for his impromptu trip to space in "Avengers:
Infinity War," the MCU's Spider-Man is a
self-described "friendly neighborhood" hero who's
more comfortable going on grounded, street-level
adventures. Unsurprisingly, many of the heroes
he hasn't met in this universe are of the cosmic
variety — and you can't get more otherworldly
than the God of Thunder himself, Thor.
The first time Spider-Man and Thor had an
opportunity to meet each other was during
the final battle in "Avengers: Endgame." However,
they didn't even get the chance to banter — though
the webslinger did get to fly through the sky
via Mjolnir, thanks to a last-minute save from
the unexpectedly worthy Steve Rogers. After
Tony Stark's funeral, the Asgardian decided
to join the Guardians of the Galaxy as part
of a period of self-reflection, while the
spider-powered teenager continued to serve as one
of New York's few remaining active superheroes.
In the comics, Peter Parker and Bruce Banner
are among the brightest scientific minds in
their universe. As for their alter-egos, while
the Hulk is one of Earth's mightiest warriors,
Spider-Man's no slouch in the
strength department, either. Thus,
it would have been simultaneously amazing and
incredible to see Peter Parker talk science
with Bruce Banner — and to watch Spider-Man
and the Hulk have a Marvel-ous team-up.
While Spider-Man was busy helping Tony Stark
bring in Steve Rogers in "Captain America:
Civil War," the green behemoth was off-world.
In "Avengers: Infinity War," Spider-Man lent
a much-needed helping hand to Iron Man in
fighting off Cull Obsidian, largely because
the Hulk didn't want to come out of Bruce
following his defeat at the hands of Thanos.
It doesn't seem like Spidey and Bruce had much of
a chance to trade contact info during the battle.
While Webhead and Jade Jaws both pitched
in during the final battle in "Avengers:
Endgame," the two could-have-been-Science-Bros
didn't really get the chance to partner up.
All things considered, the Guardians of
the Galaxy would probably seem like an
interesting crew for Peter Parker: a weirdly
charismatic team of oddballs and outlaws with
a strange sense of humor. While he did get
to converse with half the team in "Avengers:
Infinity War," the fact that Peter hadn't had
any meaningful interactions with Rocket, Groot,
or Gamora should be rectified
in a future MCU production.
As for the other half of the team, Spider-Man
fought alongside Star-Lord, Drax, Mantis,
and Nebula on Titan, in a failed attempt
to take the Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos
before he could complete the Infinity Stones.
This ended in Spidey and some of the surviving
Guardians getting dusted and staying dead for
five years. Upon their return in "Avengers:
Endgame," Spider-Man found himself allied
in battle with the Guardians once again,
as well as a time-displaced version of Gamora.
However, despite being on the same battlefield,
Spider-Man didn't really get the
opportunity to meet the rest of the crew.
When Ant-Man sided with Captain America's team in
"Captain America: Civil War," he didn't have Wasp
on his side. For a brief period of time, though,
the Wasp almost made it to Team Cap's roster,
before the Russo brothers decided that the
story of her introduction would be better
served in a movie that didn't already have too
many characters and storylines on its plate.
While the decision to have Scott Lang
join Team Cap without Hope van Dyne
ultimately allowed her to have a proper official
costumed debut in "Ant-Man and the Wasp,"
it was still a missed opportunity for the stinging
superheroine to butt heads against Spider-Man.
Spider-Man and the Wasp would later get a shot
at fighting on the same side in "Avengers:
Endgame," following their revival after
getting dusted by Thanos. However,
they still didn't get the chance to interact
with each other during the extremely crowded
final fight — and despite the fact that
they both showed up at Tony Stark's funeral,
audiences didn't get to see them
meet each other or swap stories.
Despite her significant role in Thor's early MCU
mythology, Lady Sif hasn't been seen that often
in subsequent movies. In fact, she didn't even
show up in "Thor: Ragnarok," and was confirmed to
have died during the Blip in "Avengers: Infinity
War." It's safe to assume that like the rest of
the heroes brought back in "Avengers: Endgame,"
the fierce Asgardian warrior was alive during the
final battle against Thanos, but audiences didn't
get to see her if so. Incidentally, this also
meant that Spider-Man likely never got to meet
her or witness her abilities on the battlefield.
Realistically, there probably isn't much that
Spider-Man and Lady Sif would have to talk about,
nor would they really have any solid reason to
interact. Nevertheless, it's always a treat to
see how a conversation between an Earthling
and an Asgardian goes — especially if said
conversation involved the jocular Spider-Man
and the somewhat serious Lady Sif. Either way,
hopefully they get along
better than Sif and Loki did.
"I hope you know you deserve to
be alone and you always will be.”
Speaking of the God of Mischief, if
Peter Parker ever gets to meet Loki,
their encounter would doubtlessly
be full of hilarity. Spider-Man's
humorous jabs and naive observations would
probably amuse, or irk, the trickster god,
while Loki's penchant for deception and
dishonesty would likely befuddle the
webslinger. That's why it's a shame these two
characters have never met in an MCU production.
Despite the fact that Loki has
been on Earth multiple times,
none of his Midgardian adventures have caused
his path to cross with Spider-Man. While Spidey
and the rest of the Avengers were busy
trying to fend off Thanos in "Avengers:
Endgame," a version of Loki that branched out
from the timeline of 2012's "The Avengers"
ended up having his own adventures
in his eponymous Disney+ show.
If one were to be technical about it, Peter
Parker did have at least one significant,
albeit brief, moment of collaboration with King
T'Challa: At a critical point in "Avengers:
Endgame," the teen superhero snags the Infinity
Gauntlet from Black Panther with a webline,
in an attempt to take it as far away from Thanos
as possible. Despite this, however, the Black
Panther still belongs on this list, simply
because he and Spider-Man have not really had
any meaningful and direct interactions, despite
being on the same battlefield not once, but twice.
The first opportunity that Spider-Man
and the Black Panther could have had
for formal introductions took place
in "Captain America: Civil War,"
during the lengthy airport battle scene. However,
both superheroes had their hands full trying to
subdue their respective opponents and didn't
really get the opportunity for chit-chat.
Considering that Chadwick Boseman sadly
passed away in 2020, it seems that their
brief interaction in "Endgame" will be the extent
of their relationship for the foreseeable future.
Clint Barton is one of the MCU's founding
Avengers, and also happens to be one of the
most oft-underestimated heroes in the cinematic
universe due to his lack of fancy abilities.
Nevertheless, he has proven countless times that
he can hold his own in the company of Earth's
mightiest heroes, and has played a crucial role
in virtually every major battle since the Avengers
were founded. He even helped the heroes win the
day against Thanos' forces in "Avengers: Endgame."
Unfortunately, his part in that grand skirmish
did not involve meeting Spider-Man at all.
Among all the MCU's superpowered heroes, Peter
Parker is perhaps the most human. Without a doubt,
he would find some form of kinship in Clint,
who could probably teach him a thing or two
about acting more mature and getting over his
insecurities in front of the costumed superhero
crowd. If Hawkeye's uneasy partnership with
Kate Bishop in the Disney+ "Hawkeye" series
is any indication, the Avenging Archer
would actually make a better teacher
for a young hero like Spider-Man
than he'd be willing to admit.
Spider-Man and the Vision fought side by side in
"Captain America: Civil War" under the leadership
of Iron Man. However, much like the other
heroes that joined Team Tony, Spider-Man didn't
get the chance to interact with the Infinity
Stone-powered synthezoid on the silver screen.
This lack of interaction between Spider-Man
and the Vision in MCU movies is a missed
opportunity for the young scientist to be
able to understand cutting-edge technology
and artificial intelligence from a radically
different point of view. In a world full of
gamma-powered monster men and hammer-wielding
gods, an artificial being like the Vision
still pushes the boundaries of modern
technology — and there's little doubt that
the science-inclined Spider-Man would be thrilled
at the prospect of talking to a lifelike machine.
On the flipside, spending more time
with Spider-Man could help the Vision
to better understand what it means to
be a human being. Hopefully, a future
Marvel movie could provide an opportunity
for Peter to flex his scientific prowess
while helping the Vision in his mission
to come to terms with his own humanity.
For the first decade of the MCU's run,
Shang-Chi has been completely absent from silver
screen depictions of its world-shaking events.
And because the superheroic martial artist only
made his debut in 2021's "Shang-Chi," it's not
surprising that he hasn't had the chance to meet
many of the MCU's heroes, including Spider-Man.
That said, it's worth noting
that "Shang-Chi" takes place
after the Blip was undone and likely before
the events of "Spider-Man: Far From Home."
In other words, when Shang-Chi
first shows up on everyone's radar,
Peter Parker isn't on the run yet as a result of
Mysterio blowing his secret identity wide open.
Realistically, there's plenty of time
for Spider-Man and Shang-Chi to meet.
Maybe Shang-Chi could teach Peter Parker a
thing or two when it comes to martial arts.
"You have the wrong guy! Does
he look like he can fight?"
Despite being on Earth for an extremely long time,
the Eternals have been conspicuously absent from
virtually all of the major battles that kept it
safe from alien invaders and would-be conquerors.
This explains why the MCU heroes, including
Spider-Man, have never crossed paths with them
in previous films. However, with the departure
of many MCU mainstays following the events
of "Avengers: Endgame," there's plenty
of room in the sandbox for the Eternals
to play — and just as many opportunities for
them to get tangled up in Spider-Man's web.
In an interview with Screen Rant, the cast
members were asked which MCU heroes they'd be most
excited to work with. Interestingly, two of them
name-dropped Spider-Man. According to Don Lee,
he'd love to test his strength against the Hulk
or team up with Spider-Man if he reprises his
role as Gilgamesh. Meanwhile, for Lia McHugh,
who plays Sprite, the answer is a no-brainer:
"[O]f course, Spider-Man. Tom Holland, duh. I
would absolutely love to be in a movie with him."
Hey, get in line!
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.